super Earth
our home
our way of life but Freedom doesn't come
free
[Music]
look familiar
scenes like these are happening all over
the Galaxy right now and you could be
next
that is unless you make the most
important decision of your life
prove to yourself that you have the
strength and the courage to be free
join the hell divers
experience true Freedom requesting air
support
the freedom to travel the Galaxy
and secure the resources we need to
build a better tomorrow
the freedom to encounter fascinating
life forms and introduce them to our
sophisticated technology
freedom to make new friends
and represent the best of what super
Earth has to offer
become part of an Elite peacekeeping
Force and work together
to spread prosperity
Liberty and democracy
become part of something larger than
yourself
become a hero
become a legend become a helldiver
[Music]
becoming a held ever may result in
decapitation or morbid occasion not all
he'll never survive